what an exciting day here at the bonfire
Comedy Central radio sirius XM 95 I'm
big Jay oakerson that handsome sumbitch
Dan Soder over there hi and long day fun
day of the bonfire activities long fun
day I got I came in early to the office
cuz I was just in the city and I got to
watch them come in from a meeting yeah
I'm a comedy meeting ain't no ho Jacob
sign in here goddamn it
Jacob walks right in the office and he
goes hi bombed I don't know happened
yeah it just went bad
there's great do bad he didn't do
anything bad it's just a meeting he
thinks it's a performance yeah
when they checked in with Jenny I'll
stick my landing it's sloppy you know me
and Merc face were laughing at him
because he was like didn't I try to do a
one hand cartwheel and I got nervous I
got nervous on those ices Anders prison
rules I called out the biggest guy and
then I just check it out I shook up he
got me a guy asked me what size shoe I
wear I said your size bitch
[Music]
but then we went to Adele Frisco's as a
family we did comedy suck us out to a
very fancy lunch
very fancy I ordered the bisque up top
which is a real that's a real
Colorado like Colorado like miss out
like your warmest soup if I could have
it I'm little I got my sheepskin or I
got the shrimp cocktail was it on a
plate
sure dude am I gonna make it a whole
thing that was such a single mom
preparation I got your shrimp doesn't
this go over ice cuz you want me to go
get you a bowl ice that's where we're at
right now people - you two going through
the tails off - but just the sauce
across the top like you're wrestling
yeah alright get out of my face but it
was fantastic everything tasted good we
had a good meal but unbelievably we made
a new friend we did we made a new friend
of the bonfire are we both sitting here
in our heads thinking what do you call
this mission server that sounds weird
Christina and I did time in the biz I
think everyone else has worked a little
bit but Christine and I met waiting
tables at Dos Caminos third Avenue and
joining us from Del Frisco's our server
this afternoon more importantly vo
artist actress and there was something
else black Lou singer yeah Sara
it is our lovely lovely new friend Jenny
heat he Don he Don heat on Pete Tong
heat on it spelled heat on Michael peaky
no Alex Bianchi or Michael Kiki Michael
J Fox show prep got me today Jenny you
were lovely today and then we came back
here afterwards to do our pre records
show yes as many of you will hear on
Thursday we have already discussed this
at length because Jacob are produced
producer who's getting the remote he's
getting the remote right now and yeah
and get printing out our topic list
because he's all giddy and nervous he
came back and did not know we were on
the air
Mike's we're live Mike's real live he
walked in the room as you all here on
Thursday and you'll hear by the way for
those of you who campers when you're
listening on Thursday enjoy this right
now he's looking frustration he walked
in the halls with a furrowed brow look
of frustration on his face and he comes
in and I go I go what's wrong but he
goes nothing's wrong I'm just in love
with our waitress yeah and I was very
sweet where he is let me tell you
something I was looking a big knife yeah
I don't know if that makes it all I
can't wait to have her eyes know he is
and everyone in the room will agree he
is one of the most sweet spirited and
we've been trying to fight so the fact
that he was like hey waitress
he didn't say love he was like very
lovely and attractive he'd be walking in
the room at any moment holding a remote
when he walked in we gotta act like we
didn't tell you he's the guy who was
here who left that guy he ordered the
filet 8-ounce rare I believe and saya
telah and aside south no butter
he was position 5 he was no butter
position 5 I just have you wondering why
it's cuz it's body sick dude yeah now it
was revealed by the way he'd be so boned
up that she remembered his order at all
right there's only three choices
yeah no bacon now gay or der yeah got a
great body but we know from being
outside you you said you have a
boyfriend I do yes he doesn't know that
he doesn't know that so this is gonna be
a debilitating blow in a way that it's
this is just do we is it a slow roll do
we just let it out mmm I think we wrap
all right let's look alive anyways and
that's where I said I'm not working a
double because I closed last night
so I staples so I said to him I said
Jacob take the whole week off you got to
travel out to the world's biggest dick
competition he says he says I can't eat
I have to check the thing yeah that
means check the thing chiming they make
them like you know it gets to the final
destination but still you know with the
whole the whole time
Jacob rejoins the show now we were
talking to our lovely new friends yeah
Jenny Eaton this is Jacob Jacob
beautiful girl sitting next to you may
be the wrong day to wear a salonpas
medicated pad yeah well we didn't know
listen we stumbled into this because as
you'll hear on the Thursday show Lou
black Lou came downstairs and talked to
Jenny and that's why that's how she got
to the show as I said on Thursday black
Lou I said you're like in Forrest Gump
and they give him the two guns and he's
jumps in the hole could you go get like
I'm down I'm on it we got it was it a
nine top it was under a be like tractor
down
so hauled first yes the hilarious part
what on your side how did you hear about
it she came upstairs and I had I got
slammed actually you guys I thought I
was leaving and you guys came in and
then they gave me three other table
that's not a bad luck shift
as a former lunch closer I was
excited that was great
just wonderful to meet you can we ask
you cuz we didn't pay a Comedy Central
paid for the bill mm-hmm was the tip
good tip was great yeah I don't know if
you know Jacob was a little lake as he
has to work out twice in the workday or
else he's not fooled himself yeah that's
why I stay away from the butter I don't
know if you'd noticed yeah I don't know
if he knows that he likes a vinaigrette
no butter he's a badass I hope you
noticed about Dan but Dan must not like
seeds on his bread because they were all
in agreement everything inside of Dan
not to order a glass of milk with his
dinner
I know this boy I know this boy do you
guys have milk because you're so bummed
you didn't get milk with your meal with
a sandwich of milk yeah
and ginger ale kid oh my god yes and our
new ginger ale is it's spicy it's real
ginger I don't like it so the table was
sitting behind me at position 7 the two
guys which I I do one of the things were
right after lunch I saw Jay and I were
walking down the stairs only gave me
enough I know I give up let me say this
I out because I should have given
you a heads up the guy was so
animated in hilarious trying to he was
he was like this big loud guy he's like
George Lee said he wanted his friend to
understand his friend couch much he
liked him
respected him and he goes George you got
to understand I've been doing business
with you for a lot I was like he got
very animated but he's a regular you
said and as I wrong and saying that's
kind of his energy that he's like a very
but the energy I don't think it he could
have been talking about how to water a
house plant and that's the way he talks
yes gets so excited that point I swear
to God you got to see this
was he a rich guy that comes in it's
expensive I think I think he was
definitely on a business meeting so
you're a server in Midtown as Christine
and I were and you deal with a very
specific type of clientele which is
shitty rich businessmen right they
probably treat her with a certain they
treat you all there so bum they see her
going to different tables and you're
come up and going like you guys want
more sauce I'm not joking right now I
worked a rare dinner shift in these four
I worked on 50th and third which
was like in 2008 and said it was like
Blackstone there's like a bunch of hedge
funds
they're lehman brothers and they were
all right by there and these four guys
ordered these all expensive margaritas
like $14 margaritas and this this girl
devynn who's like 5 foot 3 and so cute
and she's like and 53 got sacs for a
businessman for margaritas no Michael
all right and I've never seen
disappointment there so bump oh they go
I go hey guys Taylor's there's those
margaritas you guys wanted polo boys up
whew that's a great shirt oh yeah
knuckle pants
right in the right places loose in the
right place you guys drinking at 5:00 my
kind of dudes yeah yeah it's a
immediately one of them was like aw man
you're our server and I was just so
defeated that's right dude you guys ran
I go yeah I'm your problem now do
we reuse the tortilla chips like every
day just giving them cool facts about
laning but I'm turning about your
there's real tomatillos in this do we do
rat races around 11:00 I catch about six
of them sumbitches back back house don't
literally give up but I it was one of
the only tables where I transferred back
because I was like these guys don't want
me managers let me get your micros card
this is a problem I'm gonna open it up
and give it to Devin cool but then when
the older like housewives are coming
from Connecticut because we were a bi
like the waldorf-astoria and they go
shopping whatever I just a 24-year old
alcoholic that's charming in the day I
was up till 2:00 a.m. drinking
rail shots of whiskey
is there a flirtatious nature on purpose
- uh - serving at a place like that at
all I think to some people like myself
it becomes a little bit a part of the
show and it's yeah and it's one of those
things where you end up being well you
just you you want to be nice so you
always start off as nice and I feel
except to some degree a lot of you
just like it's weird to have somebody be
nice to me it's funny server so I try to
be genuine with it it's funny I already
drinks that information differently like
like Jacob and the loos were smitten
everyone thought you were sweet and
beautiful I just go right I don't even
over think that because I'm like well
this girl wouldn't me in a million
years anyway so I checked myself out and
my girlfriend's right there the old
ball-and-chain is sneezing like but I
think it's what you do it so subtle it's
what when I hate it is the sit down in
the booth is that not that but it's
mostly like Hooters when you're I mean
South Park did it the best with race
yeah exactly but exactly sit down it
goes what are you two handsome gentlemen
like you can your like just like stop
just I don't know this is the only place
open like please can I have a chicken
fingers it's not it's not that though I
mean I'm talking about the girl they sit
down and like they're they're really
like they they go to every table and
kinda like only you cool guys I get it
miss just out we're gonna tip she goes
that's one of my favorite lines in that
South Park episode she was like ah it
was so boring at work til you guys
showed by the way I'm the guy that buys
all of that and I'm everything the
business dude when I was at Hooters and
I was 17 and I've definitely told this
story before on the show alright the
waitress at Hooters just blew me away
with that energy is the first time city
or I was like we're gonna shove this
lady and I'm just a 17 year old kid that
drove there in an astro van with his
friends and I ordered the spiciest
chicken great oh what's the spiciest you
guys gosh you guys watch your eyebrows
sweaty I got terrible diarrhea and then
is pulled into a gas station and an
AAMCO station I just took like a raging
dump and I do have a friend by me
pepto-bismol in heavy metal doors like
mulch was a real man wouldn't Easter
super mild stuff
I would like to be your husband it was
well what do I got to eat get my picture
on the wall I want to be next to really
sad what I think
DJ Lou has that you have that - I've had
several friends in my life come up to me
in like the even the limited times in my
life I've gone the strip clubs
I've all but several the times I've had
a friend come up to me and be like dude
like I think I'm gonna go in the bag
this girl keeps saying like that she
thinks she's really thinks I'm hot like
we should go in the past for a couple
dances yep dude totally my let me just
go back and then go down the line and
like say to everybody that's not even
hidden well it's like hey sex and if you
go I know from being young when we would
go to the strip clubs and being broke
but you want to go Matt goes no I can't
go in the back I mean they go from being
like bebe boo boo you like I don't have
any money they go go all right baby but
and they would do that and my friend
what I do when he goes I don't know man
he goes do you have any couple bucks
like a bar because like this when she's
saying like that I'm really cute and
stuff so like she's sick all these other
guys in here and they're like wow dude
but I think there's a weird because it's
not by the way ugly guys who would I'd
say no it's the ones I'm thinking of or
better looking at other than I but it's
a personality type where there's guys
that I'm sure my when I drank beautiful
bartenders were my Achilles heel like I
would just if a beautiful bartender was
like what are you doing about me and I
wonder if we're gonna get married here
but oh I mean I'm sure my mom's gonna
wanna go my mom likes a travel bag I'll
have another one and then I'm just like
hammered like do you have a boyfriend
why are why are we sharing a cab but
that's like the up part of being
in the service industry is you're
especially as a woman you have to like
deal with drunk businessmen and
Christine you've probably dealt with
that I know you have it Dos Caminos
where you just see the drunk guys coming
in their life what let me take you out
of this shitty place what are you doing
here and that's a job earn money do you
get that a lot in this location I do yes
yeah I got you get I got save you money
like that kind of
like seeking money but just like I'm
sorry I don't mean to be Jacob but
yesterday like right up behind that not
no I won't do that no I just I I do it
happens it happens all the time it
happens probably like once or twice a
week and once a week just as you break
this down what three times see is just
as our table it happened with the two
loud guys next to you two humans illegal
you can break those you can lover you
can kill international waters whatever
you want they love you I don't care you
can be a new daughter the both of you
actually asked me the same question the
table behind you George
asked me he was just like how often do
you get hit on during the week he asked
me the same question to George a just
like which is interesting because he
didn't also he was made a big deal about
it being like one to two times a week
and it probably is more because I got
hit on last night at this party
and it's just like you sit there and
you're like how can I keep this
relationship going yeah and not have you
not want to buy drinks from me if I'm
like cocktailing at your party
they're like out up there in the party
environment right as a server you have
to be there to be like and like we do
pool and stuff to a certain degree so
it's like we can share those tips
together and that's like fine by me but
like it's interesting that you said that
too and you know I I actually have a
boyfriend so for me it's like industry
as well Joel just I just sounded like it
sounds like a giant Jenga just collapsed
as this hotshot have a one-bedroom in a
story of Queen question does this idiot
know anything about Titanic I'm sorry
[Laughter]
all year round is this son of a bitch in
the business so he's the bartender there
he's the bald guy with the beard
that's a cool description of the dude
Paul yeah the beard bald guy with a
beard G a space-filling have you uh
before you had a boyfriend that you ever
date anyone from working somewhere I
mean not not from who working with you
also buying a customer Oh
somebody who give me your number yeah I
went out with a few guys real first year
that I worked there was like three years
ago I went out with a few guys cuz
during the especially during the
holidays I don't know that that kicks it
up a notch but it's like you're taking
care of parties and people are like you
remembered that I don't want bacon and
vinaigrette and you don't want any
butter and
Jenny stop I thought the chicken
do you have guys come in and just get
hammered during the day yeah and
they hit on you the most
no really no what's the most
inappropriate offer you've got is anyone
just ever just a flat-out sex straight
out asked to buy me for the night dinner
it was and it was what the number was
gonna be and it was he was gonna name a
price and it was gonna be a take her
leave you don't think there's any word
is just it was just it's so what was he
like was he uh he was uh he just drank a
lot of wine it was a wine party long
sleep on down shirt over a Pearl Jam
t-shirt no Russian I think he's rushing
cuz he's bald
no told me many times that he was was he
a purple teeth boy really did he have it
in like the corner of his mouth like one
of my mom drinks too much wine and it
gets into the corner of her mouth and
she starts crying about the drugstore
closing down the street like for skin
you know my mom's like you know leather
I grew up you could buy people okay he's
there the thing he was he just like you
never
men with men like me like that kind of
energy no I can show you basement of
bingo home
you ever been to Brighton Beach damn you
want to wake up right early tomorrow by
matching tracksuits hope you like adidas
sweat it's all I live to serve this guy
well that's actually true and not true
like if I don't feel like I can handle
it my managers do actually swoop right
and handle it and they like they will
boot rawski say hey you see that guy you
see that up but he's wearing he just
asked by me he just said what we don't
we don't get dessert
well how about you for dessert no
seriously I will take you for dessert
she's the sexiest voice for when you do
and it was like son we don't have flan
the complete and utter like
dehumanization no no I I knew that he
was like dehumanizing me and I didn't I
didn't I gave a but I didn't really
because I was more impressed with how he
came at it like he deserved it and I was
lucky for him to say it to me and it was
like I was just like wow you really
believe what you're doing is not wrong
at all I could like beast I could step
back from it and be like okay you just
don't know but I don't want you here
what did if ease the blow if he threw a
number though I'm gonna make it going
Wow no that wouldn't no matter what no
matter what number
what's your number I mean there's
not well for me and come on you can say
numbers to me that'll bit of offend you
I'm sure I got 30 bucks on the lotto
tickets for Jay great job it's got to be
the scratch off the game like the bingo
or the and I just I don't want to just
find out if I win or lose I want to
experience something yeah we got it
we're game
make it game yeah I want to earn it at
least no for me I mean what's mine I
mean that it's hard to say for a guy
such a different game for sure but I
mean if some guy was saying literally a
half a million dollars for the night you
I'm not saying you take it no matter
what I can see being insulted by the
dehumanize I'm not arguing that I'm just
saying
on pure curiosity we do not be curious
to know the number he's gonna you were
not prepared to take $17.75 yeah what
were the numbers if you don't mind us
asking there was five grand five grand
there was five grand for night one was
what kind of guy was that another drunk
Russian another wine teeth-brushing
[Music]
businessman but not from this country
Constitution that's Turkish Oh Christine
hates the Turks
yeah she's Armenian don't bring it on
joining us for the last hour a good
friend of the show just funny son of a
bitch and a great man
Graham K well thank you very much I'm
the bear Canadian singer Rick Moranis
yeah that's I've heard that in several
social circles a lot of people are
saying it a lot of people are saying
that you SAT and since Rick Moranis Wow
yeah hurt skinny John Candy you know he
he quit showbiz to take care of his dumb
kids it's one of the saddest stories in
the world his wife died and he was like
I'm out I'm gonna take care of my kids
and you're like that is such the
coincide oh you brought one water cool
Jacob we don't have a new guest and OH
son of a bitch had you dead to rights
thought you had my dead eye on you oh
yes I know they really really uh
head-fake you too it goes here you go
honey and then one for you too it ain't
just about you sweetheart
keeps baby graham you were a server yes
Jenny of us were having I served served
in Afghanistan didn't don't don't know
stolen at an Arby's in the Green Zone
yeah to go dude I worked at the GI
Friday's the Green Zone those guys blue
you wanna walk with apple bees in Dubai
dude
good night I work for ships from here
living like a king suck a dick Rainbow
Room all right yeah eat it
Russian tearoom I'm sleeping on
a waterbed in Dubai Dubai one of those
places where it's clean where did you
work at you did just blatant blatant
racism again its xenophobia have been
through enough sir I'd only work at
places that were popular in the 90s and
just about to go to business I used to
work at a Halloween themed restaurant
near Times Square yeah they used to have
like all these like animatronic things
that would like talk to you and stuff
yeah and they would all be broken and
they would have with a huge rat problem
we I'm a team player and we had a bunch
of rats and they tell us to tell people
that they were animatronic rats and I
swear people would people would believe
just by in a minute guys it's
animatronic look wow that was good
offered an a lap dance and told me
thought he's really handsome I'd be
taking I'd save you it save you from his
life you know baby hanging upside down
unless you want you baby girl
what's great is there's were people that
went back to their towns
and they're like in New York City I went
to a restaurant that had the most
lifelike animatronic rats I've ever seen
in my life and their work are now over
your father and he just had the best
time and they're like those are for real
New York City sewer rat robot
pick me just takes a Hulk out
and she's like oh oh I am bleeding
her
[Music]
you